[Music]
reshonda
is in tucson michonne is short on time
now let's try again how can we help
um i got some advice from a financial
advisor that contradicts your advice
so i wanted to get your opinion well i
would my opinion would be they would be
wrong
[Laughter]
why would i change my opinion
right so my husband and i wanted to pay
off our house
really quickly because our uh interest
rate is super low it's only 2.75 percent
and our financial advisor said that it
would be better
to make that money plus on with the 19
percent
did you say a 19 game that's what we got
this year we know that's not going to
know
average yeah yeah yeah it might have
this year but he didn't say he didn't he
didn't project that for you i hope
because they go to jail
okay the uh uh so here's the thing chris
hogan is sitting next to me did a book
called
everyday millionaires we studied 10
000 millionaires you know how many of
them said they became millionaires
by the strategy that your investment
advisor told you
zero zero
oddly enough the average they did two
main financial things that made them
their first one to five million
you know what they were chris first of
all
first and foremost they invested in
401ks 403bs
roth iras and iras the second thing they
did rashonda is they paid off their
homes
and right at 10 years now these were 10
000 millionaires
not a financial advisor not one
of them became a millionaire by not
paying off their home
and using the money to invest in making
the spread
not one of them isn't that interesting
it is so it's not like my opinion versus
his
it's like all the data says he's wrong
and the reason is is that a paid off
home sets you free
in so many ways emotionally spiritually
mathematically
everything else to be able to go on and
live your life in a way that you can
invest when you when you have a paid off
home
and you have um a hundred thousand
dollars less in your investments and a
pandemic hits
you don't have the same feeling as you
do when all that money is in investments
and your home is not paid off in a
pandemic it's
oh and the market goes down and you're
scared to death watching the news at
night
i wasn't scared watching the news at
night
i was sad for some people that were
scared
but i wasn't scared is that because i'm
stuck up or arrogant no
it's because i don't have any debt and i
got a pile of money
it's a pretty simple equation it really
is one your financial advisor should
adopt yeah and rashad here's the deal
you know the fact you know the reality
what you do when you bump into stupid is
you just smile at it and there's a
phrase we say here in the south
bless your heart but what you do is you
continue to move on your path
yeah and you move on from this financial
advisor to one that's not trying to make
money he ended up making commission when
you pay off your house
i mean that's just it's just wrong yeah
so i mean
i i understand but they're leaving at
you're leaving out risk
and when you put risk in the
mathematical formula it does away with
the perceived returns
and the investment world is not a lot of
the folks haven't figured that out in
that world
and it's it's just a wrong and again the
data
of people who actually built wealth
backs up what we're saying but you do it
you can do whatever you want
it's all good